we're now going to think about one of my
most favorite theorems in mathematics
and that's the squeeze theorem and one
of the reasons that it's one of my most
favorite theorems in mathematics is that
it has the word squeeze in it
a word that you don't see showing up in
a lot of mathematics but it is
appropriately named this is oftentimes
also called the sandwich theorem which
is also an appropriate name as we'll see
in a second and since it can be called
the sandwich theorem let's first just
think about an analogy for to kind of
get the intuition behind the squeeze or
the sandwich theorem
let's say that there are three people
let's say that there is imran
imran let's say there's dia
and let's say there is sal
and let's say
that imran on any given day he always
has he always has the fewest amount of
calories and salon any given day always
has the most number of calories so on a
given day on a given day we can always
say dia
eats
at least as much
at least
as much
much
as imran
and then we can say sal
sal eats
at least
as much not just to repeat those words
as dia and so we could set up a little
inequality here on a given day we could
write that imran's calories
imran's
calories
on a given day are going to be less than
or equal to these calories
these calories on that same day
which is going to be less than or equal
to sal's calories on that same day
sal's calories
on that same day now let's say that it's
tuesday
let's say on tuesday
you find out that imran
imran
ate
1500 calories
and on that same day sal also ate sal
also ate
calories
so based on this how many calories must
dia have eaten that day
well she she always eats at least as
many zimrons so she ate 1500 calories or
more and but she always has less than
the num or equal to the number of
calories sal eats so it must be less
than or equal to fifteen hundred well
there's only one number that is greater
than or equal to fifteen hundred and
less than or equal to fifteen hundred
and that is fifteen hundred calories so
dia must have eaten fifteen hundred
calories this is common sense
dia
dia must have had 1500 calories and the
squeeze theorem is essentially the
mathematical version of this for
functions and you could even view this
is imran's calories as a function of the
day sals calories as a function of the
day and these calories as a function of
the day is always going to be in between
those so now let's make this a little
bit more mathematical
so let's let me clear this out so we can
have some
space to do some math in
so let's say that we have the same same
analogy so let's say that we have three
functions let's say f of x over some
interval is always less than or equal to
g of x
over that same interval which is always
less than or equal to h of x
over that same interval so let me depict
this graphically so let's depict it
graph graphically right over here
so
that is my y-axis
this is my x-axis
this is my x-axis and i'll just depict
some interval in the x-axis right over
here so
let's say h of x looks something like
h of x looks something like that which
make it more interesting
whoops this is the x-axis so let's say h
of x
looks something like this
so that's my
h of x
let's say
f of x looks something like this maybe
it does some interesting things
and then it goes in then it goes up like
this so f of x
looks something
like that and then g of x for any x
value g of x is always in between these
two so g of x is always in between this
i think you see where the squeeze is
happening and where the sandwich is
happening
so this looks like a if h of x and f of
x were bendy pieces of bread g of x
would be the meat of the bread so it
would look something like this
now let's say that we know this is
analogous analogous to saying on a
particular day sal and emiron ate the
same amount let's say for a particular x
value the limit as f and gh approach
approach that x value they approach the
same limit
so let's take this x value right over
here let's say the x value is c right
over there
and let's say that the limit
the limit
of f of x
as x approaches c
as x approaches c is equal to
is equal to l
is equal to l and let's say that the
limit
as x approaches c of h of x
of h of x is also
is also equal to l so notice as x
approaches c
h of x approaches l as x approaches c
from either sides f of x approaches l so
these limits have to be defined the
actually the functions don't have to be
defined at x approaches c just over this
interval they have to be defined as we
approach it but over this interval this
has to be true and if these limits right
over here are defined because we know
that g of x is always sandwiched in
between these two functions therefore on
that day or that for that x value i
should get out of that food eating
analogy this tells us
this tells us
if all of this is true over this
interval this tells us that the limit
as x the limit as x approaches c of g of
x
of g of x
must also
be equal to l and once again this is
common sense f of x is approaching l h
of x is approaching out g of x is
sandwiched in between it so it also has
to be
it also has to be approaching l and you
might say well this is common sense why
is this useful
well as you'll see this is useful for
finding the limits of some wacky
functions if you can find a function
that's always greater than it and a
function that's always less than and you
can find the limit as they approach sum
see it's the same limit then you know
that that wacky function in between is
going to approach that same limit